[Music]
i started poking her
just joking around that's just how i am
you know she took my hand
and she looked my finger oh okay and i
was like
i was like told me what do you think
we're doing around just
chilling like
i am a virgin because i am asexual and
haven't really had a desire to have sex
yet being a virgin
is really important to me because it's a
significant part of my religion
i think there's definitely a lot of
assumptions made about people who are
virgins
i think my favorite one is the idea that
people think you can look
like a virgin my friends have always
been wanting me to lose it my friend
wanted me to have sex with his cousin
if you had your virginity intact still
in my high school environment they sort
of just ignored you
when people heard like through the grip
fine oh that so-and-so had sex it was
always seen as a bad thing
it is mandatory that we keep ourselves
pure
until marriage i lost my virginity
at 15 at a party in a garage
[Music]
hey i'm brie i'm a musician and content
creator
hi hi guys my name is rohan
and i'm a virgin my name's skyler i'm
just a normal dude
and i'm a virgin hi i'm keaney i'm an
artist
and i'm also getting a degree in marine
biology
and i am a non-virgin hi i'm vanessa
i study psychology and theater and i am
a non-virgin
i'm nico i'm 19 and i'm really scared my
mom's going to see this
if you agree with the statement please
walk to the circle
i feel or felt ready to lose my
virginity
for me i guess i i've always been ready
i just never really
found the right person and i'm not
someone that's very
uh it doesn't really matter who it is
but i just want there to be
some sort of connection between us i
don't want it i'm not just gonna like
hit it and just like all right you could
go home kick them out you know
that makes sense i mean at the time you
feel ready
because they're like she looked good i
look good it's time
time i'm ready was it did you know the
person for a good while before you guys
i knew i knew it for a time i wish i
knew her longer it was my first high
school party
the whole time i was feeling like dang
this is my first time
um i don't know what to do it was
like i don't i don't know what to do she
looks nice did she expect me to do
everything
do it like it was it was a lot of stress
it was i just remember being super
stressful
i think i was sweating and then like i
wasn't even sweating because of sex i
was just sweating like i couldn't even
put the condom on right it was like
it was just what it was interesting i
identify as asexual
and i've never really felt comfortable
in the past in like the past couple
years or when i was in college
to lose my virginity versus now i've
come to a place where
i'm more of like a sex positive asexual
be the term
and if i had a partner nowadays or
someone that i like
deeply connected with i would be down to
the idea of it but it's still not
something i'm like
seeking out or whatever but if like my
partner was like
yo this could be like fun or something
and if i would do something random with
them
like maybe i would have sex
so the question was do you feel ready to
lose your virginity and for myself i am
not ready
um because i am muslim and technically
you're
or actually you're only allowed to lose
your virginity or be intimate with
anyone once you're married
so i am not married nor am i in a
relationship or have i ever been in a
relationship
so i am just saving myself saving
everything until marriage so
um once i get to that point in my life
then i'd be ready to
do that the right way with my partner
when i first
lost my virginity i remember it was like
talking to a guy for a couple days on
tinder
um he was just like i have
a place do you want to come over it
finally happened we get into the room
and it just sort of starts happening and
i was just like
take a deep breath ask him if he has a
condom right
and then let's just do this and it
happened
he was apparently so high that he had
forgotten that
he had sex with me in the first place oh
my god i got a text message the next day
being like there's carl's jr in my
fridge what did we do
oh my god i was just like i can't do
this no i need to find somebody else do
you regret your decision at all are you
like
you're good with it what happened it
wasn't my favorite experience
but i don't regret it you know i gave my
consent i
went through it and i was just like okay
i understand what i want now
um for me it was
not completely consensual so it wasn't
really my choice
um he was like kind of threatening to
like break up with me if i didn't
i was just like well i love him so much
and i don't want him to feel like i
don't love him
and so i ended up doing it and to be
honest like i don't remember
much in the experience just because like
i dissociated a lot i was like trying to
protect myself
but i don't regret it because
i did my best with what i had and like i
it's just like i don't think i could
have changed anything because i
vocalized like when i was uncomfortable
and it just
he didn't really care so um
i definitely was not ready but um
i do have a better relationship with sex
now and i've made like a lot of progress
too that's good yeah that's healing
thanks right yeah well thank you for
sharing wanted to stamp
that that happened to you everything
does happen for a reason and it's a
learning experience so it only
goes up from here yeah yeah yeah um
i do believe i learned a lot but
it feels weird to be like that happened
for a reason because like
in a way that would almost excuse his
behavior yeah and i know like
with like good intentions like
everything does happen for reason i
totally believe that too
yeah and i did learn a lot from it and i
don't think i'd be here like talking
about it if i if it didn't happen so
right i get like how the universe works
and
it's just how it happened but um
that's like not to say that what he did
was okay yeah absolutely
i was taught what consent looks like
okay can i have all my disagreers please
come forward
seeing you guys all here love our
society and school system
in sex ed we were taught how to put a
condom on
what chlamydia is what aids is
you're taught everything except you guys
even want to do it
you know it's a great point okay so i
went to an all-girls private school
and then we were partnered with an
all-boys private school as well
when i asked them what their sex said
was like they were like the teacher said
we know you're gonna do it so here's how
you do it here's how you put the condom
on they told them
everything for us it was taught by my pe
teacher
right and so then he was like the best
way to prevent pregnancy is to be
abstinent and i was like
that tells me nothing what does it mean
and then they never talked about consent
like within that either
and so when i reported my sexual assault
incident which wasn't the one that i
described earlier but
um i like did say no
and so i brought that up to their
attention and they were just like okay
but you stayed in the relationship after
so that basically means you're
consenting to everything else
and i was like that's not what that
means like even legally
and so i know and so then i went to my
school counselor and she was like i have
a friend who's in a different police
department
so i talked to that police officer and
he was like you could probably press
charges against
the first police department that you
went to but i was just like so over
talking to different police officers i
was just like this is too much so i just
left it at that so
i think what's wrong is the fact that no
one can agree what consent looks like
like what the green lights are what the
red lights are and just like even a
yellow light that should be stopped
that makes a lot of sense it's really
well said yeah
i learned that whenever something
happens i kind of freeze
and i was um assaulted at one point
it was during a dance those dances i do
admit they kind of turned into a grind
fest
and you know that's all fun and
everything like that but then
this one guy who i was with started
getting very touchy with me and it's
very
cramped like i try to move somebody
pushes me back
i can't like leave so first thing that
happens to me is like my body sort of
freezes
and it was kind of like a should i let
him keep going should i keep playing
until i haven't out
and it my mind was kind of racing but i
was kind of frozen at the same time
and then finally he took my hand
took me out of the crowd and started
walking towards the bathrooms
i just ran off and i went and found my
friend group and i was just like
he thought i was consenting that was
definitely not it
so it definitely was kind of hard to
figure out
the idea of concept at the time yeah it
sounds like you just
assumed and yeah you should never assume
someone has consent yeah yeah
i'm i'm really sorry that happened yeah
and especially i was a sophomore at the
time and i was definitely very much a
virgin so i was just like
no way in hell am i doing this right now
well for me for the longest time consent
means marriage but i realized that
that's not always the case because there
could be assaults in marriage like if
you don't want to do it then you don't
have to you know because it's your body
your choice and just because you're
married to that person doesn't mean
you're obliged to you know
follow through and do that with them so
um i just have a vague idea of the whole
subject because it's kind of like an
untalked about topic
in our religion and but um just
hopefully down the road once we actually
get to that point then we're
we gain more knowledge and education on
it so it could be a better experience
for everyone
i actually grew up in minnesota in a
town of um a thousand people
so you know really awesome sex education
is so fun honestly it wasn't it wasn't
probably the worst but since i'm asexual
i don't really have a sex drive either
or whatever so i was like
that's so confusing i should try to
figure out what this is and so then
with my first like boyfriend um
we had been like dating we met like
first week of college and everything and
it was going all swell and everything
and then it was kind of getting to the
point where you like assume would
probably like you know start like
kissing or like
have sex and stuff like that and i was
starting to get really like anxious and
nervous like
how am i gonna tell him not only that
i'm a virgin i guess i didn't really
care
that much since we all like you know i'm
still young but the idea of being
like i like don't want to really be
physical with you
really was eating at me and the idea of
having a conversation that's like
intimate like that is always hard for
anyone
and i didn't know how to bring it up to
my partner at the time and we were just
like in his dorm room or whatever and i
just started like
crying and i was like i don't like know
how to tell you this but like
i like identify as asexual and like if
you don't
want to be with me because i won't like
have sex with you like i understand
like i like felt broken which is
something that a lot of asexuals feel
but it's so
not true like everyone is valid and
everyone
can be loved and you don't have to have
sex to be intimate with someone and i
just remember in that moment such a low
point
and just always growing in communication
from there on out and i hope no one ever
has to feel like
they have to feel like someone won't
love them because they won't want to be
physical with them or something so never
entirely had to deal with that only on a
few occasions
um one in particular i was just picking
up a lunch pail from for my friend
from work and we worked at different
shifts than
the girl ahead of us and i texted her
like hey can you bring my friend's lunch
pail over and i knew she was into me
just by the way she would look at me and
she would try and talk to me like okay
and then
we just ended up hanging out in her car
and we're just talking that's just how i
am i just like to talk with people
totally cool with that um and then
i started poking her just joking around
that's just how i am
you know she took my hand and she licked
my finger
oh okay and i was like
i was like me what do you think we're
doing
right we're just chilling like like
right after
she she straight up told me that she
wanted me to [ __ ] her
legit like that i was just like
i literally i stopped looking at her i
sat in my chair i was like
what i was just like trying to process
everything like
i thought we're just vibing and we're
just showing and that that was
that was a turn on but then also a turn
off is like that wasn't my
intent for you to come over i just
needed you to bring my friend's lunch
pail
yeah and uh you just want to get it on
like that
it made me feel a little weird around
here because i thought we were like
going to be friends
and then it was just straight shot
somewhere else yeah i think it's
interesting that if
like a more femme person more to present
the story the
like narrative would be totally
different and i think it's really
interesting
to consider like if a guy like came on
to a girl like that
during like a lunch work thing the
circumstances would be so much
different versus like we're kind of like
laughing with you versus like no i like
that you said that because
those kind of like biases pass us all
the time we never
really realize them until someone brings
it up and you're absolutely right
because i totally would have changed the
whole
like the way i saw everything i've been
like that's so scary it's just how it is
for like for the male
if you're more you know masculine they
expect you to always want sex all the
time
you know but sometimes it's not what you
want to happen
and it's not really spoke about either
when like you're a victim of like sexual
assault
as a man or if you're more masculine
they're just gonna be like oh what was
wrong with that situation
so it's like it's in that situation like
my friends
in a joking way they would think
something's wrong with me
as in like why didn't you do it like
yeah you're gay
yeah for me i think they see it or they
have seen it
sex as kind of just like a fun activity
but i've seen
i see this so much more you evaluate
more yeah exactly exactly
so like a good foundation first yes
where you guys have that trust and like
that love embedded
exactly where it makes sense if we're
going to be doing this together i have
to feel like we're both in this together
yeah and like it goes even further than
just that moment
yeah because uh right yeah it's not
physical it's like your soul connection
you know
your souls connect and you will connect
forever absolutely yeah
i think it's also important to um note
that
not everyone agrees that it's a soul
connection
and just opening the conversation about
people have different perceptions of it
too so i think that's
important to know and that's why there
can also be like not
equivalent forms of consent to if
someone like thinks of sex as something
that's super important
and spiritual and all that but someone
else is like oh it's just like
exercising yeah just
we put too much importance on virginity
yeah i think there is too much of an
importance on it i think it's made out
to be
it's just going to be amazing and this
is how it's going to be
everyone like talks it up everyone talks
a big game about it and sometimes
it can be i've had friends who say
they're gonna wait for marriage and they
do
and then they tell me like that was it
like that's what
all the hype was about and so then
they're just like they've gone like
their whole lives identifying with this
one thing that they've never even really
experienced
and then it's just like shattered and
they've taken on this identity for so
long then they're like
i don't know who i am and like that's
something a lot of my friends have
struggled with
um i feel like there's not enough
conversation about how you feel
after the fact if you are previously
really tied to the concept of being a
virgin so i'm like 50 50 on this there
it should be importance on it
just for the fact that if you do slip
and mess up
you can have a kid and i guess that's a
big thing for me is why
i'm still a virgin is that i don't i'm
not ready for kids yet
um and also with virginity uh
ever since like all the way to for me
all the way to elementary school
i've heard girls losing their virginity
which is crazy for me to think
the joking adds to it like we all joke
around with the topics and stuff but it
just adds to
the importance that we that we view it
so i
hear what you're saying about like
we maybe need to have the idea like the
word
virgin or virginity to have
conversations about it but when you
think about it there's so many things
in life that we don't have like a label
or a word for like even just thinking
about
like oh like having kissed someone it's
all like a like
let's come up with a word for someone
just kiss someone like i'm a sex haver
i'm a kiss haver
like it's like even thinking about the
idea of virginity i think the
importance that's put on it is like very
toxic because
it is talking about like usually the
idea of like penis in vaginas
and it's like yeah like that sounds like
really like stupid to say like but it is
like what people's like i'd say
mainstream notion of what is
virginity and it's like making this like
pedestal of purity
and this heteronormative experience of
what is virginity
and i just think it's outdated
eradicated
right i think it very much like pushes
for the idea of purity culture
because if you also look at the
definition of virgin it comes from
sexually intact woman
and that's implying that it only happens
to women only women can be virgins
and that's we know that's not true i
mean right i take issue with the fact
that it also has sexually intact
like as if you lose something and you're
all of a sudden destroyed and like
you don't lose anything and like it's
still like a great experience for both
partners hopefully
it's weird that we felt a need to put a
label on that part of women who are
sexually intact
as opposed to someone bi word thing so
perfectly
right i feel like i feel like it's like
vomiting so
no it's perfect i love it i think for me
when
i don't know just the environment that i
grew up in with how high school was
i felt like it was kind of like if
you're a non-virgin you're one of us
if you're still a virgin it's just like
you kind of forget that you exist
so that was sort of like my perspective
on that
yeah i was listening i was like wow
that's really cool how you guys think
about that
for me personally for me personally um
i think there is a huge um importance on
keeping your virginity it's not more
like your virgin or you're not it's how
you lose your virginity and
how you should or we're supposed to lose
our virginity is by being married
and um so for myself like i hold the
same expectation for
my future spouse that because the same
regulations apply to him you know
he had to stay a virgin until marriage
and actually in our religion like doing
anything intimate getting close to
anything that
goes without meaning like hand-holding
or just like kissing or anything all
those are strongly prohibited and
it's because it's all sin if i fall in
love with that person if they come into
my life and they're not a virgin then it
would be okay if they understand that
that was a sin
and they asked for forgiveness it's how
it works basically
i never knew all that i guess this is
just like an open-ended question
how have your perceptions of virginity
change from when you're younger to where
you are now like
is there any difference something new
you learned yeah mine definitely has
changed for sure
and i remember like around the time
where you know i was debating about
losing my virginity and stuff like that
i kind of ran into some people you know
when i was online dating
like as soon as i tell them it's like
it's almost like they're kind of
fetishizing me in a way where it's just
like you're a virgin
i'm ready to take that and it's just
like they're just trying to figure out
like as soon as i have one date with
them they're just
like trying to get it in i'm just like
absolutely not no stay away
six feet apart right i only like asked
that because i grew up catholic so i
thought i was going to say myself for
marriage too and i grew up thinking like
it's going to be a beautiful magical
thing it's only meant for my husband and
then it
obviously just didn't work like that and
so after that happened
i kind of had a weird relationship with
sex for a while but
then it changed my perspective on it a
lot and i was like it's just like a
normal thing that people can do
and so i didn't really want to put it on
a pedestal as much as i had before
there's a lot of gray matter when it
comes to virginity now i know
a person out there that she didn't want
to be a non-virgin
anymore she want to have sex so she let
him
uh put in you know do anal instead
actually in our religion doing anal is
prohibited
it's like not allowed so anal is not
even a
like anal is not allowed um but for me
like
if you were to lose your virginity it
would be
a man and a woman having intercourse
there's no other
there's no gray area it's interesting
that the definition changes among
different cultures and religions too
yeah so that's why it's kind of weird to
be like
this is a virgin not virgin because we
all learn different things we all
believe different things exactly
so i personally i don't even like know
how to answer the question because
i don't agree with virginity as like a
word
or a concept i feel like the idea of
being open about what i have and haven't
done is more important than being like
yeah i'm a virgin like i just do what i
want or whatever i feel is like
comfortable for me so i have been judged
for my sexual or
non-sexual choices
you look at that okay it's almost like
you can't do anything without being
oh my god
there was times that even i judged and
then
i was now i look at it i was dumb
an idiot you know because when i was
judging i was probably like
in high school still i was still
immature it was just very immature
actions from me
and then now i have hindsight with it it
makes me think like why
is their actions their beliefs affecting
my day
this question gives me a lot of anxiety
um
because like i have been like called
like [ __ ] like [ __ ] like that doesn't
bother me
but um my experience is a little
different because
when i was assaulted and i started
talking about it
i had to talk to my mom and um
she kind of like asked me like well why
did you like get in the car like why are
you at his house and
um i guess like putting more of the
blame on me which is really difficult
because
she's my mom and she's like sorry
thank you
um she's like supposed to like take care
of me and like
uplift me and it's just hard because
i like go to her with this like huge
thing that happened i mean just for her
to react
like why would you do that it's like i
i don't understand like why that was my
fault
and like everyone like always tells me
like it's not your fault and like i know
that it's just
it's hard like sometimes i'll get caught
up in being like oh i guess it was my
fault because i did choose to date him
and like i did stay
but to my credit like he was like
mentally abusive and like sexually
abusive so i didn't
know how to leave and i
grew up thinking like oh you date to
mary and so i wanted to make it work so
badly
and so that's like why i stayed and like
i just wanted it to work out and that's
how like
i was just taught um and so then like
after the whole experience i was like i
guess like i need to be able to take
care of myself and set my own boundaries
and know when to leave and it's sucks i
had to learn it the hard way
but at least i know now and i know it's
not my fault and like
it is like something that still sticks
with me from time to time but i'm
learning how to like be better with it
thank you for sharing yeah probably have
a different experience than most you
guys
or i guess all you but like with being
so open
about being asexual like there's not
many people who
talk about it especially online even in
real life and everything
and i feel like i've been like immensely
judged for it and even
in my videos about being like asexual
primarily on tick tock
um i get like so many death threats and
people being like
you just can't have sex like you're ugly
like you wouldn't get laid like you're a
blue haired girl
like even for me i'm like such a strong
person i feel like it's hard to get
thousands of people telling you this is
fake and even for me sometimes it's like
is this fake like everyone else feels
this way
why do i feel this way and sometimes for
me it can get like hard and be like
damn like am i broken which i know is
that true at the end of the day but
yeah i think for me um i've been judged
by like society like my peers that oh
she's a virgin
like why like you know it's everything
but it's just like the western point of
view whatever that like oh you've never
had the first kiss like
like why haven't you kissed anyone yet
or something like that and i was like oh
well i'm not allowed to
that's supposed to you know like i don't
know like and that's just like
growing up it was just harder to explain
that and it was just harder for me to
explain like
like uh accept that about myself but
then you know as you grow older and you
understand that people are just
different um you hold yourself true to
your values then you understand yourself
more you know
um so i feel like i have definitely been
judged but i feel like if i
were not to be like god forbid i wasn't
a virgin or something like that or if i
have done something i would have been
judged
especially like people um like in the
culture and the religion they would
judge me for
for doing such and such you know so it's
just like
on both ends like you'll be judged
either way i've been questioned if i'm
gay
even from my own parents uh
youtube it doesn't really bother me i've
always been
even with my friends i've always been
very open on my sexuality and
i'm a virgin and like they've they've
been really cool about like they would
joke about it but just as friends
but never really like poked me hard
enough to where like dude we're making
fun of you because we just don't like
the way you are they've always been
really cool about it so uh
i think just the way i've carried myself
with that that oh yeah i'm a virgin like
i'm not telling everybody but just like
just the way it is they've always been
pretty cool about it but
from from a judgment standpoint they've
always uh it's always been in a joking
way in a joking way
because it's not the biggest part of you
right yeah exactly it doesn't define you
bye guys
virginity virginity and beyond
you